welcome back have you planned your 2022
vacation yet or maybe it's time for a
workation after nearly two years of
uncertainty one thing's certain
travelers want to feel safe a recent
report commissioned by hilton reveals
some of the trends on the map for next
year taking a trip could go a long way
to repairing the damage done by the
pandemic we've all lost our ability to
connect with one another we were unable
to go into work we were unable to go to
restaurants and sit around the table
with our friends and family and for
frequent flyers something else we also
last a sense of identity right as a
traveler you individualize yourself and
you go experience the world around you
and you could no longer do that
technology brings security in the form
of digital keys contactless payment and
digital check-in even confirming
connecting rooms when needed 2022 is
really the year of restoration recovery
and reconnection caring for the earth
will be a priority as well as globe
trotting with your pet and for some
turning your hotel room into a working
office or a personal gym but be sure to
make time for the spa your
parasympathetic nervous system or your
rest and digest will be activated you'll
be able to feel restored and renewed for
more predictions visit hilton.com
some great